it's a local Pastor facing sexual
assault charges Bobby Smith arrested
more than a week ago in North Las Vegas
his arrest report details incidents
dating back years including allegations
that the church knew about it for years
Madison Kimbrough in our Newsroom
tonight after hearing from parents who
say their daughter was a victim
according to North Las Vegas Police this
local Pastor is accused of
inappropriately touching two women and a
girl and tonight we hear from a father
who like so many trusted those in the
church and now feels that they were
taken advantage of
when my daughter told me what told me
and I heard from her ears what happened
I believe they're right off the Jump
this father who did not want to be
identified sharing his story his
daughter's story as to what happened to
her according to him 10 years ago his
daughter was sexually assaulted by this
man 45 year old Bobby Smith of North Las
Vegas a known pastor of new beginnings
Ministries the father we spoke to
explaining how he worked side by side
with Smith and went to confront him
about the allegations but was
immediately thrown out of the church
altogether the father we spoke to
explaining how he worked side by side
with Smith and went to confront him
about the allegations but was
immediately thrown out of the church
altogether with his family not allowed
to attend future services or activities
I was in leadership in the church I was
a deacon of that church one of the
deacons so I was not allowed to step
foot once my daughter told me this her
side of the story and my wife told me
inside a story I cried like a baby and
then it turned into rage this past week
Smith was arrested and charged with
three counts sexual assault and one
count of child abuse his arrest report
shows allegations dating back to 2012.
it is a father
you feel like I let her death I took her
to church
I took her to church
I went there first as a man and then I
came home and taught my family this is
where we're going this because we need
God
and they they took advantage of us
they took advantage of our trust
Smith is currently out on bail he'll be
back in court in November in The
Newsroom Madison Kimbrough eight Innings
now